well thank you very much John for that
kind introduction good evening everyone
uh it's always a a pleasure to to be
back at my alma Mo it's it's it's such
an incredible place and when you come
back you just say you know this this is
really uh this is really a dream come
true to be part of uh of this University
as I did several years
ago
um it may sound like a mutual admiration
Society but let me say this about John
gun and his and his uh team at Dodge and
Cox uh I've been 40 plus years in the
business world I have met with hundreds
and hundreds of investment companies I
have known John and his Dodge and Cox
colleagues for nearly 25 years and I
would rate them uh if not the best
investment uh company uh in this country
certainly among the top three or four
for uh uh in uh the United States uh
their long-term uh track record of
investment returns is unequaled so well
done John and dodging
HS I wasn't able to attend all the
presentations today but for those I did
attend and from what I heard during the
Toto hour they were well received
and and were very interesting so grat
congratulations to this organization for
putting on this terrific
Forum uh for this evening's talk the
direction I received from George Schultz
and John schin was very clear and very
blunt even a banker could understand
it they said please
explain what in the hell
happened why did it and how might we
avoid it happening again so that's
pretty straightforward so I'll get right
into
it but before doing so let me read you a
very interesting
quote And while I read this think about
who it's
from
quote owners of capital will stimulate
the working class to buy more and more
expensive Goods houses and
Technology pushing them to take more and
more expensive
credit until their debt becomes un
bearable the unpaid debt will lead to
bankruptcy of the banks which will be
nationalized the state will then have to
step in to save the banks will event
which will eventually lead to
Communism who said
that Carl Marx in
1867 pretty scary isn't
it
with that good news I'll go
forward this is the sixth economic
recession that I have experienced in my
business career the worst one so far was
back in the early
1980s I know some of you uh remember it
we had the Arab Oil Embargo
14% inflation 20% interest rates 11% on
employment and a very very restrictive
monetary policy the vast majority of
savings banks failed as as well as many
commercial Banks especially in Texas the
Continental Bank in Chicago failed at
that and which at that time was the
largest bank failure in US history it
was actually nationalized and sold seven
years
later Banks were saddled with LDC debt
that needed to be restructured
especially in Latin America by the way
if banks had to Mark to Market their LDC
debt back then as we do now with so many
assets every and I mean every Money
Center bank would have been bankrupt
with practically no access to additional
Capital now although the economy economy
has still not hit bottom by any means
today uh and and we have 8 but today we
have 88.1% unemployment record low
interest rates low core inflation and
the most expansive monetary and fiscal
policy in the history of the United
States
in stark contrast the inflation was so
high during the 1980 recession the
Federal Reserve mandated that Banks
reduce their lending not increase it
like they are are demanding today in
order to slow the inflationary economy
Banks face fines and other sanctions if
loans outstandings
increased Banks totally cut off their
lines of credit to their
customers in despite of such dramatic
differences most everyone thinks this is
the worst economic crisis since the
Great Depression why is that I would
call it the worst financial crisis
perhaps since the depression but I
believe the 1980s was economically much
worse than this one at least so far so
what did happen why did it happen what
is different about this
recession what is different is that in
all the previous banking crisis
generally started with the bank's
customers having problems due to
macroeconomic issues and the economic
cycle this eventually led to credit
problems and the write down of loans and
assets this time financial institutions
themselves caused the problem not broad
economic factors not the economic cycle
not misguided fiscal or monetary policy
not an oil crisis or a market disruption
let's be honest this problem was caused
by a total disregard by Financial
institutions management of basic
riskmanagement
fundamentals even Common Sense coupled
with a serious lapse in ethical Behavior
it was fueled by greed unchecked by
regulatory authorities and reached an
unprecedented scale due to the re due to
the breakdown in previously reliable
third-party safety valves namely rating
agencies let me ask you these questions
is it ethical to rec on a mortgage
application an income that you know is
wrong is it appropriate for a firm to
sell investors the security that the
firm itself is
shorting isn't it just common sense that
especially for subprime borrowers that
stated income negative amortization
teaser rates no do and low do mortgage
loans primarily originated by Brokers
are inappropriate should never have been
offered and are an open invitation for
fraud could this subprime F have reached
the Bubble Level it did without Triple A
ratings from rating agencies could it
have reached uh that level if mortgage
brokers had been properly regulated by
their state
agencies aren't all of these relevant
questions that we should be asking so
that we learn from our
mistakes what is so unfortunate and so
puzzling about this crisis is is that it
should never have
happened it was not caused by normal
economic issues it was caused by human
air and human M fiance perhaps this is
why we have had to use such
non-traditional methods to try to fix
the problem the old tools aren't working
because the co cause of the crisis is so
unique and so
different it reminds me of the story of
three men who are about to be executed
during the French
Revolution a soldier a politician and a
banker the soldier put his head on the
guillotine the blade stuck he went free
the politician put his head on the
guillotine it stuck again and he went
free so the banker was next in
line and he'd been watching all of this
and he looked up at the blade and he
said I see the problem oil the
hinge yes we Bankers often cut our own
throats
the seeds for today's problems were
solded in the 2005 to 2007 time period
when credit risk sprads were the lowest
they had ever been across almost all
asset classes 50% or sold narrower than
their long-term averages the market was
pricing as if there was no risk many
investors were looking for just a little
more incremental yield while they
generally ignored the very substantial
increase in incremental risk this opened
the door for the greed and ethical
lapses that I mentioned earlier cleaning
up this mess has Unleashed massive
monetary and fiscal stimuli never before
contemplated yet alone used not even
during the Great
Depression incidentally there have been
many articles and comments in the media
comparing the current economic
challenges to the Great Depression
factually there is not even a close
comparison the depression's loss in GDP
was a about 10 times the decline in all
the recessions we have had thus far in
the 20th century combined in the early
1930s GP GDP fell by about
30% industrial production by almost half
unemployment exceeded 20% and of course
the depression lasted a long time
practically the entire decade of the
1930s in fact unemployment did not fall
to single digit levels until the
beginning of World War II we are far
from these dire economic levels and I
see no chance of of even getting close
given the coordinated fiscal and
monetary policies taking place around
the
world the fourth quarter GDP decrease of
6.2% is startling to many but we forget
that we have had quarterly decreases in
GDP of around 5% or more in many past
recessions including 1948 49 1953 19 uh
5 uh 8 196 60
197 uh 4 and of course again the very
difficult early
1980s nevertheless the recent economic
changes have been dramatic in the past
year alone we have seen stock markets
across the world Fall by half erasing
$35 trillion from investors portfolios
about 8 trillion in the US markets alone
for most Americans their
401ks now look more like 2011
k
Americans net worth has tumbled by1
trillion in the past year that's equal
to the annual output of Germany the UK
and Japan
combined and unprecedented 10 trillion
dollar has been pumped into the US
economy by the government the Federal
Reserve the US Treasury and the FDIC
through asset purchases loans debt
guarantees Equity Investments and fiscal
stimuli some of you remember Senate
Senor Everett Durk durksen who used to
talk about a billion here and a billion
there being real money that's chump
change now we talk we talk today in
trillions consider some of the other
startling Financial changes in the past
year fed funds reached a a high of 425
and a low of zero if you go all the way
back to 1800 the average yield of the
10-year treasury has been about 4 a
half% compared to about half that at
times this past year commercial mortgage
back security spreads uh to swaps
reached a high of 1500 basis points this
year and a low of 90 basis points and of
course we all know that crude oil prices
uh peaked at $147 a barrel and reached a
low of $33 a barrel we have never
experienced such dramatic changes in
such a short period of time we have come
from at we have gone from asset spreads
reaching all-time lows and being
extremely overvalued to significantly
undervalued today
and that's what happens when bubbles
burst this T this time led by the
housing market as home prices increased
an unprecedented
125% between 2000 and
2006 in the current credit crisis
Bankers have been accused of being
heartless refusing to make loans and
unwilling to make a mortgage
modifications thus prolonging the credit
crisis it reminds me of the
advertisement in the San Francisco
chronic for a heart transplant perhaps
some of you saw it for the heart of a
Nobel Prize winner the cost was
$50,000 for the heart of an Olympic
champion the cost was
$100,000 but for the heart of the banker
the cost was
$200,000 now George Schultz Schultz's
wife Charlotte saw this ad and she said
George she always says
George how can the heart of a banker be
worth four times that of an Olympic
champion and twice that of a Nobel Prize
winner simple George said it's never
been
used let me ask you this is it
inevitable that we have a banking crisis
every 6 to8 years as been the case for
the past three decades is it just the
capitalist process that Financial
Innovation often leads to excesses
creating Financial bubbles that when
they burst trust me they always will
causes economic shifts that often leads
to recessions is this just the price we
have to pay to gain the extraordinary
economic benefits of the free enterprise
system well I don't believe it is I
believe the extremes of the bubbles the
Tails if you will can be largely avoided
sure we will have issues mild recessions
the normal ups and downs of the economic
cycle these are likely unavoidable but
because we have so much more econ IC
knowledge today smarter and more
proactive central banks more
knowledgeable and and effective
Regulators these Cycles should be less
severe less frequent and of shorter
duration in fact this has been the
pattern of recent downturns until now
but what about the hyper bubbles that we
have experienced such as the internet
bubble and the housing bubble what can
we do about those how can we avoid them
and thus mitigate the Carnage when the
bubbles burst what can we the bank
management board of directors Regulators
do differently to reduce future problems
especially problems of systemic risks
caused by the bursting of
bubbles for the answer we must first
look in the mirror we the management of
financial of the financial services
industry must do a much better job of
risk management we the financial
services industry must be more
accountable and responsible we the
financial services industry must change
our culture and our incentive systems
should we decide to make these changes
not only will our economy Society be
better off but so will our
stockholders now my goal is not to
convince you that I have all the answers
because I certainly don't but rather to
engage you and others in this important
Forum in the discussion and the debate
the premise of my proposition relative
financial institutions is this doing the
right thing is the right thing to do if
you think it is wrong it probably is
wrong just because someone else is doing
it doesn't make it right losing market
share because competitors are not
pricing for risk or making unsound
underwriting decisions or even crossing
the line of responsible and ethical
Behavior will benefit you in the long
run why because the cost of cleaning up
the mess in terms of the write-offs and
loose and loss of market share during
the cleanup including the long-term cost
to your reputation will cost you two or
four times more than that which you
gained during doing the wrong thing just
look at what is is costing the industry
today over a trillion dollars in
worldwide write-offs some say it may go
to 2 trillion a
$4.7 trillion reduction in market value
of financial institutions from Pink from
Peak to trough so far banks have
struggled to raise a trillion dollars in
new Equity early on some of that Capital
came from the Middle East for a while
there on Wall Street on Wall Street it
was either Mumbai Dubai Shanghai or
goodbye he eventually it became goodbye
as there are no large investment Banks
left making mistakes in the risk
business just never
pays never now now there is essentially
no private Capital private Capital
available to Banks it's all coming from
the governments so here are some things
we might want to consider that could
significantly reduce future incidents of
aberant behavior by financial
institutions now I know this may sound
polanish but stick with me for a moment
first and perhaps most important is what
I would call management by culture i
Define culture as knowing what to do
without someone telling you what to do
most financial services companies today
are large multi-product multi- multi
Geographic and hugely complex their
various divisions provide different
products to different customers in
different markets they can't be
controlled and directed centrally in
fact much of the responsibility and
accountability for result s must be
decentralized to business heads often
far away from headquarters in order to
respond quickly to customers and
everchanging markets today a command and
control or hierarchial management
structure for large and complex
institutions just doesn't work even
though most businesses that make up
Financial companies today are different
Wells Fargo has closed to 100 different
businesses for example what they can
share and what they must share in my
opinion is a culture with similar vision
values operating philosophy risk
appetite and policies some call this
tone at the top but that tone has to be
heard and be sung at the bottom where it
counts in such a decentralized and
geographically dispersed model line
management must be responsible and
accountable for both risk and returns in
addition however there must be a strong
effective check and balance system that
includes internal audit risk asset
review and an Enterprise wide assessment
of risk for such areas as operations
credit risk and interest rate risk these
checks and balances supplement the risk
process but they are not a substitute
for line management being ultimately
responsible and accountable risk
management is not about math
mathematical models it is all about
people group heads Coos and CEOs must be
carefully selected for their judgment
and risk reward balance they must be
Hands-On know what's going on understand
the risk and very importantly the tals
of the risk to ensure that the operating
units are adhering to the corporation's
values Val values philosophy and risk
policies these values and policies must
be communicated throughout the company
effectively consistently and
repetitively now there are many ways to
EMB better culture in any institution be
it be it a for-profit or a not
for-profit uh company one way we do this
at Wells Fargo is through this booklet
the vision and values of Wells Fargo
first published 16 years ago with is
updated about every two years it
describes our Vision Values operating
philosophy and the culture of our
company we believe so strongly in a
unified company culture that we will not
acquire any company or enter any
business unless we believe it is
culturally compatible as you recall many
banks bought large full line investment
companies in the late 199 or in the
1990s we did not it is not that we
thought offering our commercial clients
m&a advisory services or Capital Market
capabilities wasn't a good idea we just
felt that the culture at large
investment Banks was incompatible with
ours we are a relationship focused
company large investment banks are often
transactionally focused we are a team
focused company with Team incentives
investment banks are often individually
incentive with highly paid Stars we
believe that investment Banks often
crossed the line in pursuit of deals and
market share in short we felt the
employees of investment Banks would not
accept our culture and we could not
accept theirs so it would be a disaster
for both parties
in fact we predicted that six out of 10
of those large Commercial Bank
investment Bank mergers would not work
we were wrong nine out of 10 didn't
work today no large investment Banks
even exist the only two left Goldman
Sachs and Morgan Stanley are now Bank
holding
companies another example how is it that
Wells fargle the largest mortgage
originator in the country missed the
bulk of the subprime debacle why is it
that we decided that for subprime
borrowers we would not originate any uh
option adjustable rate mortgage loans
any negative amortization mortgage loans
any stated income or or no do low do
mortgages why did we do that uh even
though we could have sold as we do with
all of our mortgages 100% of these loans
in the secondary Market at presumably no
residual risk to our company the answer
is on page eight and N of our vision and
values booklet Under The Heading
responsible Lending let me read an
excerpt to you every loan we make must
provide a de demonstrable benefit to the
customer or we won't make the loan two
we will make diligent efforts to
determine that that customers have a
high likelihood of repaying a loan
before we offer it and they commit to it
third it is totally contrary to our
vision and values to to attempt to sell
a customer any product or service that's
not in his or her best long-term
interest so the decision was pretty easy
the head of our mortgage company Mark
Omen came to me in 2005 and said I don't
think we should do the crazy things that
are going on in the subprime mortgage
Market because it violates our vision
and values and our responsible lending
principles he said we will lose market
share but it is not right for our
customers or our company I quickly
agreed there's really no long discussion
and no hesitation and we lost by the way
4% market share each year for three
years6 $60 billion we lost in Mortgage
originations in 200 in 2006 alone
similarly Dave hoit head of Commercial
Banking decided not to pursue C cdos
Clos CVS and highly leveraged loans to
private Equity firms all of which became
problematic in this crisis now I share
these examples with you not to praise
Wells Fargo as we were far from perfect
and we made other mistakes that we
shouldn't have made but to demonstrate
how powerful both culture and line
management responsibility can be to
avoid at least some of the major
problems but it takes of course more
than a booklet here are some other inal
ingredients in my opinion the management
team especially the senior management
team must walk the talk everybody is
watching what you not what you say but
what you do in selecting people for top
management positions an essential
ingredient should be their understanding
of belief in and demonstrated commitment
to the accept CED culture because
because culture is so important to
results promotions are generally from
within the company most of the time
management has likely spent the majority
of their lives working at that company
they must leave live breed teach and
walk the talk of the
culture the incentive system is also
critically important if your incentive
system is geared to to short-term
results you are asking for trouble as a
financial institution the majority of
incentive pay at the sen level should be
should be long-term in nature such as
stock options which of course are
long-term dependent on total company
results and align with the interest of
stockholders the who are the owners
importantly however every stock option
recipient should retain at least 50% of
all after tax exercise stock options
until retirement
50% this incenses people to focus on the
longterm work as a team not take
shortcuts not do dumb things for
short-term gain there should also be a
clawback provision for cash bonuses
should have be be be determined that
past earnings were improperly
recorded another important tool that may
surprise you some of you I believe that
such broad statements as corporate
objectives and a firm's underlying
business model are critical to avoiding
serious mistakes this assumes of course
that you walk the talk and do what you
say for a financial institution
long-term objectives should include
first a conservative financial position
measured by asset quality accounting
policies and capital levels you should
want such a strong balance sheet in your
bank that your customers would put their
money in the bank even if there was no
FDIC Insurance second annual growth in
earnings and revenue that are aggressive
but not exceedingly so third return on
assets and return on common Equity at
relatively high levels in the top
quartile of the industry now why why are
these important tools well if your
number one goal is financial
conservativism how can you originate
loans with without adequate covenants
make highly leveraged lbo loans with
practically no covenants leverage your
balance sheet to 50 times Equity
similarly if your financial goals
require High Returns on Equity how can
you price assets without adequately
charging for risk balloon the balance
sheet with assets that are of low return
how can you have an earnings growth rate
objective say 15% per every year and
still invest in the business without
taking excessive risk or crossing the
line another important element to
avoiding excesses is a business model
that can perform reasonably well in any
economic environment a business model
that is well Diversified by product
geography and
Industry we all know that uh every
segment of the financial services
industry is cyclical which is the bad
news the good news is that the cycle
varies by segment some segments are even
counter cyclical like now when the stock
market uh when the stock market
collapses Bank deposits increase because
Investments Park their funds uh in
banking accounts similarly in high rate
environments which usually corresponds
to a strong economy and the F which the
FED is trying to slow mortgage volumes
decline but other segments are growing
and credit losses are low in low rate
environments like now when the FED is
trying to stimulate the econ E Credit
losses are usually elevated and many
segments are struggling but the mortgage
Market is often booming which it is
today because of refinances so if you
are Diversified you can often write out
the highs and lows of the various
segments diversification helps you to be
more conservative prudent and
disciplined which will allow you to
perform better uh than the industry
because you won't pay the severe price
of cleaning up the big mistakes that
result from staying the course even when
the winds are against you
some people have suggested that this
financial crisis was caused by the
repeal of the glasto ACT which allowed
financial institutions to broaden their
product lines to include all Financial
products nothing could be further from
the truth in fact when you look at the
survivors of this crisis you see that
the most Diversified survived even
though they made similar mistakes as to
the companies that are now gone
diversification is absolutely essential
to effective risk management
I would also caution to to not over rely
on mathematical models even though that
some of those models are taught right
here at the Stanford Business
School they rarely can take into account
Wing risk in fact 99% confident levels
are not sufficient in our business the
last 1% of the risk can bankrupt a
financial
institution finally let me mention five
other areas that should be addressed to
avoid or at least mitigate the
reoccurrence of systemic risk
crisis perhaps perhaps the most cont
most important contributor to the
severity of this financial crisis as
compared to others was the role of the
credit rating agencies I just can't
believe that they could rate any
subprime mortgage security Triple A
Common Sense and experience should have
overridden their mathematical
models if the rating agents rating
agents had been doing their job we might
have avoided the majority of the issues
related to subprime borrowing and
housing price would never have reached
the levels that they did would German
Savings Banks have invested in United
States sub subprime mortgages without
the Triple A
rating another problem that needs to be
corrected is the procyclical nature of
certain accounting POS policies namely
the reserve for loan losses and marketto
Market accounting such policies need
needlessly ACC accentuate the credit
Crunch illiquidity and credit
availability why in God's name do you
you mark something to Market when
everyone agrees the market is not
functioning
properly why would the fed and the
government invest 10 trillion dollars of
taxpayers Monies to fix the market if it
was functioning marketto Market
accounting is fundamentally not about a
quote on a screen it should always be
about expected expected cash flows
however when a market is deep and
functioning properly the screen price
should approximate expected cash flows
and is an appropriate shorthand method
for Market
valuation when markets are not
functioning the screen is not reliable
and you should have the option of using
the lhand method of expected cash flows
to Value assets which importantly should
be carefully reviewed by outside
Auditors and Regulators to ensure that
the calculations are accurate we must
also change the timing and when to build
the provision for loan losses we should
build the loan loss provision in the
good time because those those are the
loans because those are the loans and
assets that we that will be written off
in the bad times that's the purpose of
Reserve accounting ladies and gentlemen
I'll tell you a little secret over 90%
of all the loans and assets that the
bank in Industry wrote off in 2008 ALL
trillion dollars worth were originated
in 20056 and early 2007 the very time
period that the SEC fby and the
accountants would not allow would not
allow financial institutions to build
credit reserves because according to
them there was no immediate proof that
losses would occur in the future that's
right I said
90% this during the time that at least
in my opinion asset spreads made no
sense were at alltime lows and were
priced as if there was no risk if that's
not a sign of trouble sometime in the
future I do not know what it is we
should also reinstate the uptick rule
relative to shorting stocks and the law
against naked shorts should be strictly
enforced finally we must admit that our
regul regulatory system failed us
because State Regulators failed to
monitor mortgage brokers there was
widespread F fraud the SEC failed to
check the high leverage and liquidity
risk of investment Banks banking uh
Regulators allowed off-balance sheet
vehicles and credit risk to get out of
control we must change our process of
regulations and Regulators so that all
of those
companies who do the same thing uh are
regulated in the same way regardless of
legal
entities now I could go on and on with
suggestions to consider that would help
mitigate the excesses of past Cycles but
time will not allow suffices to say that
I sincerely believe that we can use some
of these tools to reduce the occurrence
of systemic risk bubbles I firmly
believe that the benefits far outweigh
the cost and that these and other
suggestions can be implemented without
serious risk to financial Innovation and
and competitiveness by doing so our
nation's economic growth will be
increased and be more consistent and so
will the results for our stockholders
our customers and
employees before closing let me say a
few words about the economy GDP and this
the first quarter will decrease by 5% or
more following a 6.2% decline in the
fourth quarter and will likely be
negative uh next quarter but hopefully
at a reduced
level unemployment will soon over 9% and
and approach
10% yes our economy is suffering due to
the almost $2 trillion dollar of
deleveraging of consumer and corporate
balance sheets and the rise in consumer
savings rate which is reducing
purchases prior to the recession the
country's savings rate was essentially
zero consumers were spending everything
they earned and borrowing to spend even
more this juice consumption and the
economy to unsustainable levels it is
now being reversed the consumer is
saving their reduction in gasoline
prices and their stimulus checks the
saving rates the savings rate has jumped
from 0o to 6% the highest rate in 14
years and is heading toward the 10%
savings rate reached during the 1980
recession in the short run this hurts
the economy but in the long term it is
positive the reason we will start to see
growth soon hopefully Beginning by the
fourth quarter or early next year is the
enormous monetary and fiscal stimuli
that are in the pipeline and let me
emphasize if the current amount is not
sufficient more will come if you don't
remember anything else I say this
evening remember three words whatever it
takes that's what every Central Banker
Finance Minister President and prime
minister is committed to whatever it
takes to get their economies growing
again if you want to bet bet against
them you do so at your own
Peril conventional wisdom says the
economy is suffering from a the
liquidity crisis that's not correct cash
Holdings in households and non-financial
businesses are are actually at an
all-time high at about 70% of GDP this
abundance of cash is ready to be
invested as soon as the bottom is
reached conventional wisdom says we are
likely to see a fairly slow increase in
econom economic activity once the bottom
is reached and it might take years for
the economy for the economy to reach its
potential because of the incredible
stimulus in the pipeline very low
interest rates and the huge pot of
available liquidity I think the economy
is likely to increase quite
substantially once the bottom occurs and
the economy economy will reach its
potential much faster than most people
think the risk to Future economic growth
will come later in my opinion after
everyone thinks the crisis is over and
we will once again grow to the sky the
danger in my mind is not that we don't
start growing again the danger is that
we we will have to pay for this
extraordinary stimulus two or three
years after the economy fully recovers
perhaps with stagflation as the stimulus
is removed we pay the cost of our
extraordinary budget deficits to make my
point it is estimated the treasury will
issue $1.8 trillion in bills and bonds
this year which when combined with the
1.5 trillion dollar last year exceeds
all the net borrowing by the US uh over
the prior 27 years
combined so in conclusion if you wonder
whether or not the credit crisis will
will ever end just remember those three
important words whatever it takes thank
you for your attention as I understand
it there will be time for questions and
comments near the end of the dinner
thank you very
much